sommes rendu ces trois derniers jours à
Herson il est vrai que tous les jours
nous avons entendu les bombardements les
tirs au loin puisque la ligne de front
se trouve seulement à quelques
kilomètres du centre-ville le long du
Nièvre c'est bombardement russe vous le
savez cause de nombreux dommages tout
d'abord des dommages à des habitants
d'horaireson puisque des maisons sont
endommagées mais aussi des immeubles
imlan nous a accompliés confié que par
exemple c'est vite avaient explosé lors
d'un bombardement il se retrouve
aujourd'hui sans fenêtre alors que
l'hiver arrive et que le froid et là des
bombardements qui causent également des
problèmes vous le disiez par rapport à
l'électricité puisque les Russes
bombardent très régulièrement les
infrastructures énergétiques russes qui
pose de nombreux problèmes il y a encore
erson s'est retrouvé sans électricité un
total blackout alors il est vrai qu'on a
discuté par exemple avec la mère de
Herson elle nous a expliqué bien que les
autorités arrivaient régulièrement tous
les jours à repérer un petit peu ce
réseau électrique mais qu'à cause des
bombardements et bien finalement
lorsqu'ils arrivaient à réparer 50% du
réseau et puis bien sûr le réseau
retombé parfois à 30 40% en raison de
tout c'est bombardements les
ukrainiens et les habitants de rerson
avec qui nous avons pu discuter nous ont
expliqué bien que malgré tout après 9
mois donc passion russe et bien il
préférait être maintenant libre et
ukrainien plutôt que sous opération
russe et que la morale n'était pas
atteint malgré ses bombardements et
malgré ce manque d'électricité de
chauffage d'Internet et des conditions
très très difficiles sachant qu'ici il
commence à faire extrêmement froid vous
êtes polyn à ce moment dans la région de
mikolif quelle est la situation
comme à rerson Nicolae va de gros
problèmes d'électricité mais ici par
exemple les feux de signalisation
fonctionnent alors que Harrelson ce
n'est pas le cas par exemple par contre
il est évident que quand la nuit tombe
elle tombe très tôt ici vers 16h 16h30
et bien la ville est complètement
plongée dans le noir puis s'il n'y a pas
du tout d'éclairage public ici puis
l'électricité va et vient il y a aussi
un autre très gros problème ici c'est
l'accès à l'eau douce à l'eau potable
cela fait des mois que les habitants de
mikolave n'y ont plus accès alors c'est
aussi évidemment parce que les russes
continuent de bombarder toujours les
infrastructures énergétiques toujours
dans le but et bien de démoraliser le de
démoraliser les ukrainiens et bien il
est vrai que les autorités ont annoncé
aujourd'hui ça y est avoir ce samedi
réparer les 264 km de canalisation
nécessaire pour que l'eau douce arrive
ici à mikolive le souci est que
on revient toujours à ce problème
d'électricité comme l'électricité est
bien n'est pas accessible à 100% ici
notamment dans la région de nicolaïve et
bien tant que l'électricité ne sera pas
là et bien les pompes ne pourront pas
fonctionner pour pouvoir faire que l'eau
arrivera jusque dans les tuyaux des
habitants de mikolaive